joining us from at San Francisco 49ers
offense as a guy who have had the
pleasure to work with the last couple of
playoff seasons as he has come on the
show as a guest studio analyst I don't
think he's gonna he's gonna be part of
our playoff crew this year because he's
gonna be playing in January himself he's
Emmanuel Sanders how are you Manuel yeah
we should keep you out of our postseason
plans on NFL gameday morning all right
looking good right now what and how is
this ride been for you this year I got a
phone call around a base rate I think
John told me around 12:00 or 1:00 and I
was on the plane in like six or seven so
and I'm Susie and I had my wife and two
kids I her find Allison he's been moving
fast but as far as um you know just this
locker in general just assist a
corporation so much made the transition
a lot easier you know with people help
me help with my wife and everything and
so now yeah you know when it kind of you
know uh also helps everything as well
and turns to energy you to positive five
so you know I'm happy to be out here so
compare Jimmy G to quarterbacks that
you've played with you've played with
the you played with two first-ballot
Hall of Famers Big Ben is one that leaps
to mind and Peyton Manning being another
we're obviously Jimmy G is a lot more to
go to be considered in that group but
you've seen skill sets at the various
high a very high level what about Jimmy
G Emmanuel no I guess I got in disguise
a bit before I love playing with the guy
and I want to talk about a guy who loves
playing football cause the work every
single day you know what a positive
mindset getting the guys or bringing it
energy every time you know he's one of
those guys it's just just just winning
steps and he makes guys believe of it
you know as far as his ball you know he
throws a very catchable pass he doesn't
try to you know overthrow it with the
exceptional walk the rules but in the
game he throws a very kissable balm
enjoy playing alongside it but I tell
you what the skies are living for all
right now walk away from him and tell me
how you really feel about it okay where
are you right now are you in a meeting
room right now where are you and though
we got this place out here in which you
could like get some recovery or what
that so we're both getting recovered
right okay you and Jimmy G having a
smoothie is what you're saying
man I mean and again we're in this
training camp Rhoda uh I don't need to
tell him he tells out of school you
being north of 30 coming off of an
Achilles injury playing in Denver where
Joe Flacco's coming in and everybody's
hoping that this could be just like a
you know similar to the year where you
just add another veteran quarterback to
a situation that might be ready-made for
for something special to happen then it
doesn't happen then you get a trade now
you're in San Francisco where something
special appears to be happening you just
can't make this stuff up obviously I
love the city of Denver I love to Denver
organization but I just felt like my
time was up there you know I felt like I
needed I need to do energy you know I
had almost almost six different
quarterbacks you know five different
head coaches six different offensive
coordinators just a lot and you know I
was I was looking forward to you know
getting to organization where you know
we can compete and win it you know I
still you know wish the best for the
Broncos organization I just felt for be
a my happiness and for my little sank it
was best for me to move on it so still
when John told me you know obviously I
was I was sad about leaving the city a
different but at the same time I was
excited about going to it the
organization issue and obviously you
have good memories of winning a big game
in that building that you've now call
your home so yeah I went up this last
home game I was walking through town I
was like man like every time I go
through this one spot on the field I
remember you know walking off
soon afterwards 150 and coming back
through that tunnel and every time I
walk through I said band like that was
incredible all that in my life you know
and look at me that is you know my home
field I've been so amazing memories
amazing energy off and off it I said it
for sure well any Emmanuel Sanders here
in the richer Anderson show any
similarities to that season or
championship would be seasons in
Pittsburgh a lot of this one it's a lot
of similarity in a locker you got a lot
of growth got a lot of dogs in his
locker room he got a lot of a lot of
people who believe it says as far as you
know you know the defense that year we
had a legendary even when I was with the
Steelers in 2010 when I was there so
hold yeah Troy Polamalu with James
Barrie and James Harrison and all those
guys got a legendary defense in this he
says compares well you want to talk
about Easter some line I can get to the
ball on a second area that could cover
it so finale has a lot of baggage that
could run in here so you know I'm
excited about the defense I know if we
have our business office it's gonna be
hard David beat us if we take care of
the football or put a voice Emmanuel
Sanders here on the Rich Eisen show are
you gonna take some time Sunday you
think to peek out on the field when your
defense is out there because of who
they're trying to stop on us yeah I pick
that every time I enjoy watch out guys
late but definitely oh you know we're
watching our incredible season but you
know no I I'm sure but uh
what what what is being discussed about
Lamar Jackson in your locker room I
already put on a show so you know what
we were going up against and obviously
oh you know I hearing the defense talk I
look forward to when to see where they
stand as a decent so as a team as a team
really looking forward to you know going
out there you know Baltimore that had
the past reality so we'll see what type
of which I was we have
so it's a challenge you know and we're
looking forward to it yeah I know what
the thing that I'm looking forward to
seeing too is it's two teams with
similar sensibilities and mentalities of
just hitting people
you know just hitting people and being
physical and run run and maybe the pass
comes out of the run and you know you've
been a part of many high flying offenses
have we seen a turning of a page here do
you think in in the NFL where where
we're gonna see sort of a renaissance of
running and physical mentality and
hitting people and making sure defenses
understand what's coming at them and
they have to think twice yeah I think so
you know and I'm happy because that's
when I first got it that's what's best
browser distillers you know I'm playing
in and you know that's the type of
division I was used to it of every game
was a cold bad game you know especially
play that is only playing in the AFC
North and so I like that I like that
aspect about football I think that's how
it should be you know because wins
championships and I think that was what
we're starting to have this game will
see that you get this blood officer play
today they'll go out and pay plays but
people are really trying to build a
business why I have defense because you
have a style defense that you like the
odds go up you know the odds the odds in
your favor try to win a championship but
if you have a lot of baggage that could
run a secondary I can write a flying
tackle but the only thing is it fell
down right now with all these $25,000
fine for forgetting which I don't like
it and I'm an office player but at the
same time I think it's a bad thing you
know the hitting is what the fans love
this thing oh then you know obviously
the fun kind of take away from enjoying
the game well I mean you know I'm sure
many in the league would say they're
trying to just protect the players
trying to protect you immanuel yeah yeah
but you know I come from old school
football come from when I first got in
the league it was to an age I can't
believe I'm talking like this talking
like a homo but you know when I came in
it was two days and they
hey guys really weren't getting all that
banged up and so you know some some of
it I understand but some of it I don't I
don't really like it so you know it's
always gonna be like that right it's
never gonna be completely you know oh I
love this always gonna be like yeah it's
kind of its kind of kind of cheap but it
is what it is you know Emmanuel Sanders
here in the Rich Eisen show a couple
more minutes left with him
who's playing Lamar in in ensconce
counting like two hours okay if they
need me to get back there do it I'll do
it
that's what I was about to say I mean
maybe you could do it right I mean how's
your arm how do I have to talk down
might have to target kana see if I go
play Scout to even do it how's your
honor can you can reallocate that yeah
good I might talk to college see if I
can do it seriously okay I mean cuz
that's a crucial role here okay so you
know how it works in the paparazzi
immanuel so the headline I'm turning to
my producer Chris Brockman send out a
tweet from at Rich Eisen show Emmanuel
Sanders says he's as good as Lamar
Jackson tell me tell me how I'm wrong
tell me how that's not factorable what'd
you just say you said that next to Jimmy
G overheard that Emanuel enjoy whatever
what what Thanksgiving will you have
with your family do you have one or
aptitude
it's a weird schedule we got got
Baltimore and do we got the Saints so
gonna be on the road for ten days
because for the East Coast
I got a Florida practice out there and
then play against the Saints and come
back so even though I'm having
Thanksgiving I got a
because we've won right it kidding yeah
I mean you're gonna if the Niners wind
up with the one seed I mentioned on
yesterday's show you are gonna earn it
sir you got at Baltimore at New Orleans
Atlantic comes in your house then you've
got enough to division games where
records do really get thrown out home
for the Rams and then at Seattle could
be for the division 1 seed or maybe a
road playoff appearance as as an absurd
like 12 win wild-card team I mean
something could ward 13 win wild-card
team like that could be possible you
know very possible they're gonna discuss
when I see it uh so we just we just shot
a shuttle win each game at a time and
obviously see what it shows well yeah
okay well tell Jimmy gee you know don't
be a stranger here you know we we want
him on the show too you know
now doc can you say that out loud to him
right now when he say so once again
Emmanuel Sanders says he's not better
than Lamar Jackson and and and when
asked for the truth for Jimmy G didn't
say anything got it okay fire moji fire
all right let that let that simmer on
Twitter for a couple hours take care of
yourself a manual thanks for the call
Congrats on everything going on with you
we'll chat soon that's right back at you
that sanders underscore 10 on twitter
and at Emmanuel Sanders on Instagram for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 under red TV for
free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app